In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 2, on which we commemorate the Holy Marjor
Mamas.
On the 2nd of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Marjor Mamas.
Saint Mamas came from Gangra in Paplegonia, Asia Minor.
His parents, Thildotus and Rufina, were faithful Christians and confessors of the faith.
They were cast into prisons by the pagans for refusing to deny Christ.
And Mamas saw the light of day in a prison cell in the year 260.
Since both his parents died in prison, the little orphan was adopted by a pious woman called
Amiana, or Matrona, as some say.
He became known as Mamas when he was a child because this word for his foster mother was
ever on his lips.
Before her death, she warned him above all else to keep himself from idols.
When he was 15, Mamas was seized by soldiers in Caesarea, the chief city of Cappadocia,
for refusing to sacrifice and for persuading his companions not to do so.
He was sent first to Democritus, the governor, and then brought before the emperor, Aurelion.
Seeing his tender years, the tyrant thought to win the boy over with swift flatteries,
but soon discovered that Mamas' spirit was stronger than a diamond and a flame with divine
zeal, more than the most fiery furnace.
Aurelion was enraged to have a youth boldly hold his own against himself, the master of
the largest part of the world, and had him cruelly beaten.
Imagining that he had broken Mamas' spirit, Aurelion said, now simply say that you have sacrificed
to the gods, and I will release you, neither in my heart nor with my lips, will I ever
deny Christ my Savior, Mamas replied.
On the contrary, I thank you, emperor, for these torments that enable me to love Christ
more and to unite myself to my king who suffered for my salvation.
Seeing torches were applied to his entire body.
His limbs were battered with stones, and he was cast into the sea with a leaden weight
around his neck.
But an angel of the Lord transported him to a high mountain, overlooking the city.
Glorifying God in ceaseless prayer, he lived there among the wild animals that offered him
their milk for food.
After some time, in the strength of a sign from God, Mamas went down the mountain and
gave himself up to Alexander, the new governor of Cappadocia.
He was again put to the torture which only availed to reveal in all its brilliance the grace
of God in his soul and body.
He was thrown into a fiery furnace where he remained like the three Hebrew children, telling
forth the glory of God and protected from the consuming flames by a dew from heaven.
In the end, pierced through with a fork, Mamas found the strength to make his new way out
of the city where he surrendered his soul to God.
When a voice was heard from on high, calling the martyr to rest from his labors, in the
eternal habitations, through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our
God, have mercy on us and save us.